hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute einen
richtigen leckere banana split torte ich
hatte schon so oft im tiefkühlregal
gesehen darf mir die wohl schmecken mag
weil ich kaufe in die tiefkühl toten
weil ich einfach viel zu viel freude
daran haben sie selber zu backen und die
torte besteht aus einem saftigen schoko
boden dann haben wir leckere bananen
dazwischen eine stracciatella creme und
das ganze mit kakao und schokolade
getoppt ich zeige euch jetzt aber
zuallererst wie wir den saftigen schoko
boden herstellen
und dafür benötigen wir ja die habe ich
hier in eigelb und eiweiß getrennt
außerdem weiche butter zucker mehl bacau
speisestärke backpulver und eine prise
salz und fast hätte ich es vergessen wir
benötigen außerdem noch etwas lauwarme
milch damit unser schoko boden gleich
richtig schön saftig wird brauchen wir
eine baiser masse und deshalb habe ich
die eier getrennt jetzt gebe ich weiß
zusammen mit der prise salz in eine
schüssel und stark dass ungefähr 30 bis
60 sekunden cremig
jetzt geben wir die hälfte des zuckers
mit dazu und schlagen das nochmal
komplett steif
eure baiser masse ist fertig wenn ihr
sie einmal umdrehen könnte und dann
nichts rauskommt rausgekommen gibt sage
ich hatte schon farbe crew noch weiter
geht's mit den restlichen zutaten jetzt
nehme ich mir eine größere schüssel zu
helfen und gäbe da die weiche butter die
habe ich 35 aus dem kühlschrank genommen
zusammen mit den restlichen zucker ein
und schlage das mit dem mixer cremig die
butter ist jetzt hell cremig also ein
ticken heller und da geben wir nach und
nach die eigelbe mit hinzu
[Musik]
als nächstes bereiten wir die trockenen
zutaten vor die gebe ich alle in eine
schüssel und verlor sie gut miteinander
[Musik]
und jetzt arbeiten wir die trockenen
zutaten abwechselnd mit unserer lauwarme
milch in die eier masse rein und dafür
nehme ich jetzt meinen sie damit auch
keine klümpchen entsteht und dann immer
schön abwechselnd
[Musik]
und jetzt müssen wir nur noch diese
leckeren schoko masse mit der biomasse
verein dafür nimmt euch am besten einen
großen xaver und hilft dass in zwei drei
schritten ganz vorsichtig unter den
schoko tag habe ich jetzt in meine 26 cm
springform geführt den boden mit
backpapier ausgelegt und sonst überhaupt
nicht gefällt das ganze an der
oberfläche etwas glatt gestrichen und
jetzt wann dann der teig bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze in den vorgeheizten
backofen nach 18 bis 20 minuten ist der
schoko boden fertig ich habe noch die
stäbchen probe gemacht zur sicherheit
und wenn ich zugeben selbst dann ist der
boden durch ich lasse ihn jetzt
auskühlen und in der zwischenzeit machen
wir schon die leckere schriftsteller
kleben und dafür benötigen wir kalte
schlagsahne magerquark kim frech oder
wahlweise schmandt außerdem seine stand
mittel vanille extrakt puderzucker
schokoladen saß bin hier habe ich zeit
bitter genommen etwas zitronensaft
bananen da könnt ihr euch aussuchen ob
ihr die ganz reifen nimmt oder die noch
nicht so reif sind das ist
geschmackssache und später noch etwas
barkauf für die deko die creme ist
supereinfach hergestellt das verspreche
ich euch wir geben jetzt zuerst die
kalte schlagsahne mit dem creme fraiche
und dem magerquark einmal in die
küchenmaschine und rühren das ganz kurz
miteinander glatt
[Musik]
jetzt haben sich die zutaten bei
niedriger stufe ganz kurz miteinander
verbunden jetzt geben wir vanille
extrakt der zucker unter sand stand
mittel mit hinzu und dann wird das
solange geschlagen bis es komplett steif
ist
so die creme ist jetzt schön steigt da
kommen gleich noch damit es eben eine
stracciatella creme wird kommen gleich
noch diese schoko später mit rein
ich gebe jetzt aber ein teil von in
meinen spritzbeutel für die deko denn da
möchte ich keine schoko später mit drin
haben
das waren jetzt ungefähr 250 gramm der
ganzen krämer schätzt dass ungefähr die
viele für die oberfläche braucht und
zudem rest geben wir jetzt noch unsere
schokolade
[Musik]
die stracciatella creme ist auch schon
fertig ich habe sie jetzt aber noch in
den kühlschrank gegeben weil hier
drinnen ist ungefähr 40 grad ist total
waren heute ich kümmere mich in der
zwischenzeit um den boden der ist
komplett ausgekühlt hab ihn jetzt auf
eine tortenplatte gestürzt und jetzt
nämlich erstmal das backpapier unser
schokoladen wurden ist super saftig ihr
braucht ihr nicht mal extra trinken es
ist vollkommen so in ordnung wieder ist
und ich habe den auch von der höhe her
genauso hoch gemacht wie wir ihn
brauchen wir müssen ihn also auch nicht
durchschneiden
was als nächstes machen ist einfach
einen bug rahmen drum herum legen und
dann geht es weiter mit den bananen eine
banane habe ich mir jetzt in 1 cm dicke
scheiben geschnitten und die gebe ich
jetzt direkt auf den schoko boden
[Musik]
und da man ja wirklich ganz schön braun
werden gebe ich da jetzt noch ein
bisschen zitronensaft dazu also nicht zu
viel dann habt ihr auch später beim
anschnitt nicht die gefahr dass es bei
längerem herum stehen vielleicht noch
braun wird und das schmeckt ja auch
später gar nicht raus also macht euch da
überhaupt keine sorgen
[Musik]
wie stracciatella creme ist jetzt auch
auf unserer torte ihr müsst ihr auch
nicht so glatt verstrichen da kommt doch
jetzt sowieso noch unsere sahne creme
oben drüber
und hier habe ich eine offene stelle und
damit spritze ich jetzt ganz
unregelmäßig einfach sterne auf die
torte
[Musik]
ich habe mir so zu entschieden dass ich
nur außen herum die sterne spritze und
dann kommt da noch ein bisschen besser
kaum laufen können auch ganz normal
trinker kauf nehmen aber bei cacau sieht
einfach so richtig intensiv braun aus
und jetzt gibt es das ganze zum kühlen
in den kühlschrank so ungefähr ein bis
zwei stunden und dann können wir es
endlich mal servieren und probieren ich
freue mich schon
[Musik]
und nachdem kühl zeit könnt ihr den
banana split endlich servieren ich nehme
jetzt direkt mann stück also allein der
boden hat jetzt zehn punkte
den liebe ich ja und jetzt probiert mal
zusammen mit den bananen und der
schriftsteller creme lecker also ich
muss ich sagen so schokoladig auf dem
boden also der boden ist super
schokoladig sage ich euch und die cremes
total weich und schmeckt nicht zu doll
nach sahne und durch die kleine schoko
stücke schmilzt das ganze im mond und
die banalen und so meinen heirat perfekt
macht es unbedingt nach ich hab euch die
genaue mengenangaben unten in der
infobox aufgeschrieben freue mich auf
fotos mit dem hashtag ihs kitchen auf
instagram ein bisschen nach oben wir
auch nicht schlecht und ansonsten freue
ich mich wenn ihr beim nächsten mal
wieder dabei sein
weiter geht's
[Musik]
ich finde ich gerade auf den höfen warum
bist du so lang du genießt das richtig
das ist das zweite stück haben sie tun
ist
[Musik]
es gibt aber noch ein bisschen lauter
nicht